hallo mein name ist luca und ich bin
derzeit im urlaub in österreich und habe
vergessen ein video vor zu produzieren
deswegen habe ich bei twitter gefragt ob
er irgendwelche video fragen mal wieder
hat weil das ist ja so dass typische was
ich mache wenn ich irgendwas vergessen
vor zu produzieren da wurden mir sehr
viele fragen zugesandt und wirst du zu
den video des täters zu 16 kann ja ich
denke schon aber ich bin eigentlich kein
großer fan von ihr video days weil es
ist teuer und voll und man hat es ist
teuer und es ist voll ich weiß auch gar
nicht ob die diesmal wieder in berlin
und in köln stattfinden werden aber ich
werde denke ich bei beiden sachen dabei
sein problem ist halt ein bisschen ich
hab noch praktikum bis märz gut luca die
videos sind diesmal jedenfalls studiert
hat noch neben bayern muss gucken wie
ich das alles unter einen hut kriege
aber ich denke zu 85 3% jahren die
findest du gleich zwei bisher und vespa
wusstet ihr dass vielleicht noch
passieren soll ein allerdings immer noch
nicht mitbekommen haben ich bin der typ
class 2 noch immer mit dabei wie das
passieren konnte weiß ich nicht ich will
mir komplett zufrieden mit dem
kompletten uplay stimmig feiert das volk
victory kostenlos und die anderen drei
darauf die reihe
es ist super cool ist es 0 3 das projekt
mega professionell gemacht alles also
ich feiere das komplett und ich möchte
gar nicht immer schlagen was ich mir
wünsche weil sonst störe ich die glaube
ich in ihrer eigenen kreativität
ich find's cool wenn balotelli kommen
würden
hab ich mich fest gefällt ich hier am
besten ja mir gefällt daran eigentlich
am besten so die menschen so ein
bisschen und das ist halt nicht so ist
wenn man irgendwie werden man nach
berlin fliegt sind ja alle so ein
bisschen stressig immer so ein bisschen
merkel wenn man nach süd oder einen ort
sehr allgemein fährt das alles ein
bisschen toll und ruhig und in
urlaubsstimmung sind das gefällt mir ich
ihm wollte die frage auch so beantworten
wie du sie mir gestellt hat und die
nächste frage ist welches kleidungsstück
gefällt ihr aus deinem eigenen shops mir
gefällt tatsächlich dieses meide ich
glaube ich jetzt sogar hier mehrere feld
mai all over shirt am besten das ist das
shirt hier da ist sogar meinen mein name
ist da sogar drauf jetzt bin ich halt am
coolsten weil ich die das hat ihnen wie
man zum training an und ich weiß nicht
der stoff ist eigentlich gar nicht wie
so ein trikot stoff aber ich bin der
stoff ist man da drin zu trainieren
also diesmal die olver t shirt ich habe
übrigens auch überlegt das ganze bald
meinen anderen farben zu machen also
dann irgendwie das ganze shirt irgendwie
in den hellblauen die smartesten
dunkelblau drauf oder sorgt wenn nicht
ganz nice und wirklich ja hat er also es
war einmal so ein bisschen komisch weil
ich als er wie gesagt im urlaub bin war
seit dem 23
und da musste ich halt ein bisschen
vorproduzieren und dadurch dass ich vor
produziert habe immer an beispielsweise
siebzehnten schon das tütchen für den 23
öffnen und bin deswegen komplett
durcheinander gekommen deswegen steht
der kalender derzeit bei mir zu hause
und hat wahrscheinlich noch so drei oder
vier züge türchen ich glaube das war der
kompletteste kalender den youtuber je
gemacht hat weil es ist einfach ein
playmobil adventskalender fünfjährige
kleine mädchen wie jedenfalls war ich
heute abend wieder nach hause aus dem
urlaub und werde dann im nächsten video
die letzten türchen öffnen und nach
zeigen was passiert ist aber ich fand es
eigentlich ganz neues
das problem ist halt immer so ein
bisschen das wenn ich euch sage stellt
mir fragen kommt wirklich zu zehn
vernünftige fragen und zu 90 prozent
einfach lieblingssorte aber meine
lieblingssorte ist pfefferminztee mich
war eine lange zeit man tatsächlich auf
dem trip dass sich die latte und
marzipan und einfach komplett den
kompletten schwarzen tee komplett
gefeiert habe aber mittlerweile nur noch
bei familie wenn man wirklich den
vernünftigen fans teetrinken danach so
richtig so können beim hast du peloux
airlines haus gelassen ja das habe ich
das musste ich leider weil in diesem
hotel sind keine ukulelen runde und
wasserflaschen es wirklich der
forsbacher schwein vater gärten wird ich
denke wir hier unsere geschenke schiffen
können dabei alle die vielleicht nicht
mitbekommen haben ich hatte mal mit dem
gedanken gespielt mir ein postfach über
weihnachten zu eröffnen weil viele leute
haben wir immer so geschrieben sie ja
ich hier was gebastelt und dann haben
sie davon will doch instagram
hochgeladen und ich dachte es wäre cool
wenn ihr mir das aussenden könnte und
die mainzer und jemand ja auch super
aber ich hab's vergessen ich werde
definitiv machen das heißt wenn ihr
jetzt beispielsweise gepackt hat und die
kacke eingefroren habt ihr mit parfüm
eingesprüht und den namen rein gesetzt
hatten und ich denke das muss ja
unbedingt haben dann wacht noch ein
bisschen und dann eröffne ich bestimmt
irgendwann mal in einem postfach in
fähren oder so ich werde kein
durchgehendes postfach machen wo ich mir
jederzeit das einsenden können sondern
ich werde einfach machen dass sie mir
verein monat lang dann alles mögliche zu
schicken könnten dann das ganze wieder
weil ich darf uns wird viel ankommen
heißt weihnachten mit seiner familie
gefriert wenn du weihnachten weihnachten
vergessen wie es mit der familie gewählt
hat oder was hast du generell das meine
ich mit 90 nur bullshit ja ich habe
nachts mit meiner familie gefeiert sowie
bis jedes jahr machen wir waren letztes
jahr schon in österreich urlaub und sind
es jetzt auch wieder letztes jahr hatten
wir das glück und werden über schnee
dieses jahr
ich zeige es euch mal so viel
so viel schnee hierüber übrigens die der
stadt ruhig das ganze gerade aufnehme
ungefähr so aus und ist quasi komplett
improvisiert ein stuhl auf dem eine
mülltonne drauf ist dass das ist das ist
professionell also um die frage zu
beantworten ja ich hab meiner familie
gefeiert und wir haben irgend so ein
komplettes gänge menü gegessen ich weiß
nicht mehr was alles bei war ich glaub
ich zwar kräftig es in unserem baum
dafür darf luca ich würde gerne wissen
ob vielleicht noch bettwäsche oder
schlafen züge oder etwas anderes in
einen schubkarren könnte das ist
tatsächlich eine unglaublich gute frage
auf die ich bisher noch keine antwort
weil die sache ist ich finde gerade
irgendwie bei diesem smiley oliver ding
das könnte man super cool als bettwäsche
oder zoom ist als kopfkissen oder suppe
man könnte ihm eigentlich auch als
kissen einfach machen so ein rundes
kissen oder so ich habe ultra viele
ideen was das ganze an geht die sache
ist allerdings ist die sachen die
derzeit im shop sind halt schon komplett
sich übels gut verkaufen deswegen will
ich jetzt nicht ungern so alles mögliche
machen so franchise mädchen da ist alles
raushauen um geld zu machen das ist
finde ich ein bisschen scheiße so
richtig zeit von anderen youtuber mit
die dann quasi alles haben das hatte ich
ja damals auch dass man sich auch selber
tasten design kommt und alles mögliche
was ihr auch gut euch ankommt allerdings
finde ich mir nicht mittlerweile so ein
bisschen cooler wenn es quasi bei mir
gibt es fünf verschiedene sachen und
auch nur in den speziellen farben so
dass man wirklich nicht jeder ich will
nicht dass ich euch auf der straße sehe
und irgendwie hat dann ein grünes shirt
mit was blauen drauf und der andere das
weiß mit schwarzen und so sondern ich
möchte wieder diese einheitliche
deswegen überlege ich halt wie ich noch
andere sachen machen kann das hat gerade
überhaupt nichts mit dem thema zu tun
ich werds mir definitiv mal überlegen
mit einer bettwäsche oder einem kissen
oder so ich weiß nicht sagt ihr einfach
was ihr davon haltet ich will halt nicht
so 08 15 sachen raus bringen sondern
müsste dann dauert dann mal wieder noch
ein bisschen kombi nun auch schon zur
letzten frage
ich bin raus ich bin raus ich bin raus
ich bin raus ich bin raus ich bin
einfach raus ich bin raus ich bin
verdammt noch mal bist du auch raus ich
bin ich bin raus ich bin raus raus raus
raus ich bin ich bin einfach raus ich
bin einfach raus also ich bin dabei man
kann es nicht oft genug sagen ich bin
einfach raus seid ihr raus bist du raus
bist du bist du bist auch du bist raus
natürlich bist du raus bist du kannst
mir ganz gut sagt raus bist okay wir
sind auf jeden fall alle raus freunde
wenn es euch gefallen hat würden wir uns
alle über einen daumen hoch freuen und
dass meine lieblingstiere sind guckt sie
euch an
dies sind die besten tiere der
kompletten welt meine damen herren oder
macht recht glücklich